This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This is part two of the 2020-2021 mini-stories episodes where I interview the staff and our collaborators about their favorite little stories from the built world that don't quite fill out an entire episode for whatever reason, but they're cool 99PI stories nonetheless. We have space pens, sea sheep, that'll make more sense here in a second, circular design and a seasonal national forest populated by old Christmas trees. Stay with us. So I'm talking with Emmett Fitzgerald. What is the many story you have for us?
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗马·马尔斯。这是 2020-2021 年迷你故事系列的第二部分，在这期节目中，我将采访工作人员和我们的合作者，听他们分享关于人造世界中最喜欢的那些微小故事。无论出于什么原因，这些故事可能不足以撑起整整一期节目，但它们依然是很酷的 99PI 故事。我们有太空笔、海羊——等一下这会更好理解、循环设计，以及一个由旧圣诞树组成的季节性国家森林。请继续收听。所以，我正在和埃米特·菲茨杰拉德交谈。你为我们准备了什么微小故事？
All right, so I came across this story while I was reporting our Pete Boggs episode from a couple of weeks back. It's also a Scottish climate change story in a certain way. Climate change story is Scottish or otherwise. It is definitely your beat. But we'll get to the climate change part in a little bit. But first, I want to introduce you to Sean Terrent. She is a woman who lives on a tiny island in Scotland called North Ronald Z, which is the northernmost island on Orkney, which is just north
好的，这个故事是我在几周前报道皮特·博格斯那一集时偶然了解到的。从某种程度上说，这也是一个苏格兰的气候变化故事。气候变化故事，无论是苏格兰的还是其他地方的。这绝对是你的报道领域。不过我们稍后再聊气候变化的部分。但首先，我想向你介绍肖恩·泰伦特。她是一位住在苏格兰一个小岛上的女性，那个岛叫北罗纳德赛岛，是奥克尼群岛中最北端的岛屿，而奥克尼群岛就在苏格兰的
of Scotland. It's a really small island. It's about five miles along and one mile wide. And at the moment, it's got 62 residents. Wow. Of which you are one. Yeah, so I think when we arrived it was maybe mid-50s, so it's gone up a little bit since we arrived. There's been two more families arrived since we moved here, which has been great. The island actually had more people all the way back in the 1700s. The main industry at the time was seaweed. The island actually had more people all the way back in the 1700s.
正北方。那是一个非常小的岛。它大约长五英里，宽一英里。目前，岛上有 62 名居民。哇。其中你就是其中之一。对，所以我想我们刚到的时候大概有五十多岁（人），自从我们来之后人数略有增加。自从我们搬到这里以来，已经有两大家庭搬来了，这真的很棒。其实早在 18 世纪，岛上的人口还要更多。当时的主要产业是海藻。其实早在 18 世纪，岛上的人口还要更多。
The main industry at the time was seaweed. It's really stormy up there. There's lots of kelp just constantly washing up on the beaches. The people on North Ronalds would gather it up and it was used to make iodine or sometimes burn to make pada ash, which was a common industrial chemical at the time. So they had really booming industry in the 1700s, and they had about 500 people living here at the time. But unfortunately that kelp industry collapsed, sort of 50 or so years later.
当时的主要产业是海藻。那里的风暴非常猛烈。有大量海带不断被冲刷到海滩上。北罗纳德赛岛的人们会把它们收集起来，用来制作碘，有时还会燃烧来制作草木碱，这在当时是一种常见的工业化学品。所以他们在 18 世纪有着非常繁荣的产业，当时大约有 500 人住在岛上。但不幸的是，海带产业在大约 50 年后崩溃了。
And so the islanders who needed a new industry, a new way to support themselves, and they decided to really focus in on agriculture and cattle specifically. But the issue with that was that it's a really tiny island and they had limited space for cows. Right. And particularly, they decided that there wasn't enough grass to share between the cows and the sheep.
因此，岛民们需要一个新的产业、一种新的谋生方式，他们决定将重点真正放在农业上，尤其是养牛。但问题在于，这是一个非常小的岛屿，他们养牛的空间有限。没错。特别是，他们认为没有足够的草地供牛和羊共同分享。
And so in 1832, they came together and hatched this plant. They were going to build a stone wall all the way around the island in order to separate the sheep from the cattle. And the idea was that they would save all that good grass in the middle of the island for the cows. We were in the sheep supposed to go that. Well, that's what the story gets interesting. So the stone wall, the daik as they call it, basically pushed all of the island's sheep onto the shoreline,
于是在 1832 年，他们聚在一起策划了这个计划。他们打算在全岛周围建造一堵石墙，以便将绵羊和牛隔离开来。他们的想法是将岛中央所有优质的草地留给奶牛。那绵羊原本应该去哪里呢？好吧，这就是故事变得有趣的地方。所以这堵石墙，当地人称之为“代克（dyke）”，基本上把岛上所有的绵羊都赶到了海岸线上，
where they were supposed to survive by eating all that seaweed. So ever since 1832, the sheep have been kept just on the beaches. They were they lent to survive by eating the seaweed? And yeah, kind of like sheltering against this six-foot-high dike, which goes all the way around the island. And so this worked? Like, like, sheep were able to survive on the beach eating kelp? Yeah, so over over the years centuries, really. The sheep basically learned how to eat kelp and survive entirely off kelp. And now, if you visit North Ronald's, you'll see hundreds of sheep
它们本应靠吃那些海藻生存。因此，自 1832 年以来，绵羊一直被养在海滩上。它们靠吃海藻维生？是的，有点像在高达六英尺的石墙庇护下生存，这堵石墙环绕着整个岛屿。这真的管用吗？就像，绵羊能在海滩上靠吃海带生存吗？是的，多年来——实际上是几个世纪以来。绵羊基本上学会了如何吃海带并完全靠海带生存。现在，如果你参观北罗纳德赛岛，你会看到数百只绵羊
waiting into the waters around the shoreline and just like munching on kelp. So they tend to wait for the low tide, they wait for the water to go out, which kind of reveals all of the fresh seaweed, and then they're all flocked down. Right next to water you know if it's not too stormy and and just kind of like start feasting and you'll see them you know tackling these huge like fronds or kelp and just kind of like munching it down straight away
涉水进入海岸线周围的水域，大口咀嚼着海带。所以它们往往会等待退潮，等水退去，这基本上露出了所有新鲜的海藻，然后它们就会成群结队地冲下去。就在水边，你知道，如果风暴不是太大，然后就开始大快朵颐，你会看到它们，你知道，对付这些巨大的海带叶状体，直接大口大口地把它们吃掉，
and you'll see some animals kind of like swimming out to little rocks they're kind of like wading out to get the freshest and the best seaweed that they possibly can. It's so lovely and whimsical, little floating sheep out on your short line. It's even more colorful than I imagined. Yeah, totally. Sean says they don't look like the kind of pristine white Scottish sheep that you imagine. She says they sort of look more like a kind of like grizzled old like seafaring sailor sheep. Yeah, some of the rams just roughly look pretty battered by the weather I guess. They've got like peg legs and eye patches.
你还会看到一些动物游向小岩石，它们有点像涉水过去，为了吃到尽可能最新鲜、最好的海藻。这太可爱、太奇妙了，小羊漂浮在你们的海岸线上。这比我想象的还要生动多彩。是的，完全如此。肖恩说它们看起来不像你想象中那种一尘不染的白色苏格兰绵羊。她说它们看起来更像是一种饱经风霜的、老水手般的沧桑绵羊。是的，有些公羊粗看之下确实被风雨摧残得挺厉害的，我想。它们就像有木腿和眼罩一样。
Exactly. So was it hard for the sheep to adapt to their marine lifestyle? I mean, like how do you make amphibious sheep? Yeah, I asked Sean about this. The archaeological evidence suggests that the sheep were actually eating some seaweed before this. There's so much seaweed on the shoreline, and that's probably what gave the islanders in 1832 the idea that this might work. But after the wall went up, they had to adjust to a diet
确实。那么，绵羊要适应这种海洋生活方式很难吗？我的意思是，你怎么制造水陆两栖的羊？是的，我问过肖恩这个问题。考古证据表明，在这之前，绵羊其实就已经在吃一些海藻了。海岸线上有如此多的海藻，这可能就是 18 世纪 30 年代的岛民萌生这个主意的原因，觉得这或许行得通。但在石墙建好之后，它们不得不适应一种
that was entirely seaweed, which is actually like a pretty different food than grass on a chemical level. Seaweed is very low in copper, which is something that we all need in quite small doses, but you still need a little bit of copper in your diet to function. And what they've evolved to become is very sensitive to the copper in their diet so they can extract every sort of single milligram of copper that's available in the
完全是海藻的饮食，从化学层面上讲，这其实和草非常不同。海藻的铜含量非常低，这是我们所有人以微小剂量所必需的营养，但在你的日常饮食中，你仍然需要一点铜来维持身体机能。而它们已经进化得对饮食中的铜非常敏感，因此它们能够提取海藻中可获得的
seaweed. So unfortunately when they go on grass they can be sort of over sensitive to the copper in grass and potentially get copper poisoning. So the most copper-sensitive animals that we know of in the whole world, so they've done an amazing job of adapting to their environment in order to get what they need for them. I mean, that is so fascinating. The idea that they could poison themselves with copper because they are so adept at taking in whatever copper is available is so cool. Yeah, and it's kind of stunning.
每一毫克铜。因此不幸的是，当它们吃到草时，它们可能会对草中的铜过度敏感，并有可能导致铜中毒。所以它们是我们所知的全世界对铜最敏感的动物，因此它们在适应环境方面做得非常出色，以便获得它们所需的东西。我的意思是，这太迷人了。它们因为太擅长吸收任何可获得的铜而可能导致自己铜中毒，这个想法太酷了。是的，这简直令人惊叹。
What's amazing to me is that it's all because of this wall. You know, like they've physically changed because of this piece of human infrastructure. It's like changed their biology. That's wild. So they can't climb the wall. I mean, like it's lasted this whole time and like never had a sheep go free. No, I think that occasionally,
对我来说，最神奇的是这一切都是因为这堵墙。你知道的，就像它们因为这个人造基础设施而在身体上发生了改变。这改变了它们的生理机能。太疯狂了。所以它们爬不上这堵墙。我的意思是，它持续了这么长时间，从来没有发生过羊逃跑的情况吗？不，我想偶尔会有，
I mean, they know they get copper poise and then because occasionally they will so they get through a hole or like, and actually Sean said that there's been stories of sheep climbing onto each other's backs to get over the wall. But the vast majority of the sheep There's been stories of sheep climbing onto each other's backs to get over the wall. But the vast majority of the sheep have maintained their shoreline lifestyle over two centuries.
我的意思是，它们知道自己会铜中毒，因为偶尔它们会……所以它们会穿过一个洞或者……实际上肖恩说曾有过这样的故事：绵羊踩着彼此的背爬过墙。但绝大多数绵羊……曾有故事说绵羊踩着彼此的背爬过墙。但绝大多数绵羊在两个世纪里都保持着它们的海岸线生活方式。
Because this wall is there, and the way the system works is the sheep are owned by individual people on the island, individual farmers, but they're managed collectively. And so that includes the wall. The wall's maintenance is a collective project by all of the sheep owners on the island. And so for generations, the sheep owners sort of work together to keep this thing standing. But this wall is 12 miles long. It's actually one of the longest dry stone walls in the world. Wow.
因为这堵墙就在那里，而且这个系统的运作方式是：岛上的绵羊由个人拥有，即各个农场主，但它们是由集体管理的。这其中就包括这堵墙。墙的维护是岛上所有养羊户的一个集体项目。因此几代人以来，养羊户一直合作来让这东西屹立不倒。但这堵墙有 12 英里长。它实际上是世界上最长的干石墙之一。哇。
I mean, it doesn't have mortar. It just is like stacks of stones. Right. That makes it even more amazing that it's been so robust for so long. Well, I mean, yes and no. It's constantly crumbling and falling down in places. So it's been this years-long project to maintain it, and that's been the job of the islanders. Over the years, as the human population of North Ronaldsie has diminished, it's been
我的意思是，它没有砂浆。它只是像一堆堆石头。没错。这使得它能如此坚固如此之久，显得更加神奇。嗯，怎么说呢，既是也不是。它一直在某些地方崩塌和坠落。所以多年来维护它一直是一个长期的项目，这也是岛民的工作。多年来，随着北罗纳德赛岛人口的减少，这变得
harder and harder. At times, they built some sort of fencing to plug some of the gaps. It's been a problem. And so last year, they came together and they decided, like, let's hire some young fit whipper snapper to go to like, it was like, job it would be to just like, deal with this problem and fix the wall and make that their full-time job.
越来越难。有时，为了堵住一些缺口，他们建造了某种栅栏。这一直是个问题。所以在去年，他们聚在一起决定，不如雇一个年轻健壮的小伙子去……工作内容就是处理这个问题，修复这堵墙，让这成为他们的全职工作。
And the person who answered the job posting was Sean. It just sounded yeah, really, you know, I did like, I'd spend a lot of time on different islands in remote places and I just wanted to find a job that would have me sort of outdoors for most of the time. That's amazing. I totally see why she did that. Like, that sounds so ideal to me too. She spends most of her time just walking around the island and making sure that the sheep are on the right side
而回答这个招聘启事的人就是肖恩。听起来……是的，真的，你知道，我确实……我曾在偏远地方的不同岛屿上花了很多时间，我只是想找一份能让我大部分时间都在户外的工作。这太棒了。我完全理解她为什么这么做。听起来对我来说也太理想了。她大部分时间都在岛上四处走走，确保绵羊在墙的正确一侧，
of the wall and then looking for gaps and places where the stone wall needs to be repaired. And then it's basically on her. She rebuilds those spots by hand, using rocks that are there on the beach or the rocks that were originally part of the wall that fell down. But again, there's no mortar to keep everything together. You've got to pick exactly the right rock for the right place. It reminds me of stacking wood.
然后寻找需要修补石墙的缺口和地方。接下来基本上就全靠她了。她用海滩上现成的石头，或者原本是墙的一部分但掉落下来的石头，亲手重建那些地方。不过再说一次，没有砂浆来把所有东西粘合在一起。你必须为正确的地方挑选完全正确的石头。这让我想起堆木头。
I think it's like a giant jigsaw puzzle. But on the whole, it's really therapeutic. I think it's just to spend some time and be working with your hands. Although she did admit that the task is enormous and at times it can feel totally sycophine, like you're just sort of going around the island. As soon as you fix something, there's something else that needs to be fixed. The plan before the pandemic was actually for Sean to sort of, in addition to working on the wall to coordinate a volunteer program so that you know You'd get more people to come and visit North Ronald Z and they would help her build the wall
我觉得这就像一个巨大的拼图。但总的来说，这真的很有疗愈效果。我觉得这只是花点时间用双手工作。尽管她确实承认这项任务非常巨大，有时感觉完全是徒劳的，就像你一直在岛上转悠一样。你刚修好一个地方，马上就有另一个地方需要修复。大流行之前的计划实际上是让肖恩在从事修墙工作之余，协调一个志愿者项目，这样你就会
And but but that all has some gotten put put on hold with with COVID So it's just her and she just she just keeps at it, you know a little bit little bit every day at a time I mean it feels like a folk tale or like some, you know, modeling short story, although she doesn't sound modeling, but it has the qualities of that. Yeah, totally. Yeah, exactly. I think that that's a little bit of what drew me to it.
吸引更多的人来参观北罗纳德赛岛，他们会帮她建墙。但是，这一切由于新冠疫情都暂时搁置了。所以只有她一个人，她只是……她只是坚持不懈，你知道，每天一点一点地做。我的意思是，这感觉像是一个民间故事，或者某种……你知道的，道德寓言短篇小说，尽管她听起来并不像在说教，但它具备那种特质。是的，完全如此。对，没错。我想这就是吸引我的一点。
Is it sort of imagining her working to preserve this rare breed of sheep, you know, like one stone at a time. So that's so cool. So at the top, you mentioned that this is a climate change story. So how is this a climate change story? As you probably know, livestock produce a huge amount of greenhouse gases. Yeah. Of course. You know, through their their farts and their burps, which, which gave off methane, mostly other gases to, but mostly methane.
想象她为了保护这种珍稀的绵羊品种而努力工作，你知道的，一块石头接一块石头。这太酷了。所以在开场时，你提到这是一个关于气候变化的故事。那么这怎么会是一个气候变化故事呢？正如你可能知道的那样，牲畜会产生大量的温室气体。对。当然。通过它们的屁和打嗝，这些会释放出甲烷，主要是其他气体，但主要是甲烷。
And cows are the worst offenders here, but livestock as a whole are, by some estimates, are responsible for about 15% of all greenhouse gas emissions globally. So it's a really massive thing that we need to theoretically deal with if we're going to deal with climate change. But recently, there's been this kind of interesting development, which is that a few different scientists from around the world have studied and figured out that if you feed cows seaweed,
牛是这里面最大的肇事者，但据某些估计，牲畜作为一个整体约占全球所有温室气体排放量的 15%。所以这是一个非常宏大的问题，如果我们想要应对气候变化，理论上我们需要解决它。但最近，有一个非常有趣的进展，那就是世界各地的一些不同科学家研究并发现，如果你给牛喂海藻，
you can actually really dramatically reduce their methane emissions. Wow. Okay. That's so cool. I can see how that ties in now. And so you're seeing a ton of research into this right now into seaweeds and cattle, and which types of seaweeds reduce methane,
你实际上可以非常显著地减少它们的甲烷排放量。哇。好的。这太酷了。我看出这其中是如何联系起来的了。所以你现在看到关于这方面的研究铺天盖地，研究海藻和牛，以及哪种海藻能减少甲烷，
and how much you would need to add to their food. So you've got the background. You've got all this research going on that's mostly focused on cows, but you know sheep also produce methane. And so the thing that I guess in terms of our story, the cool thing is you've got these sheep on North Ronald Z and theoretically you wouldn't need to add anything
以及你需要在它们的食物中添加多少。所以你了解了背景。你了解了所有这些主要针对牛的研究，但你知道绵羊也会产生甲烷。所以我想就我们的故事而言，最酷的事情是，你有了北罗纳德赛岛上的这些绵羊，理论上你不需要添加任何东西
to their diet. You wouldn't do anything. They're pre-made. That's so funny. There's a lot we don't know, but the thinking is that maybe these sheep have important information, things that people can learn about how sheep and cows and their stomachs break down seaweed and what's going on in
到它们的饮食中。你什么都不用做。它们是天然的。这太搞笑了。还有很多我们不知道的事情，但大家的想法是，也许这些绵羊拥有重要的信息，人们可以从中了解到绵羊和牛的胃是如何分解海藻的，以及在化学层面上发生了什么。
kind of a chemical level. I'm sure it would be beneficial to look at the sheep that are here, they're actually surviving on seaweed the whole time. They've potentially got these unique enzymes and got bacteria that can be really useful to science. So it's just great to show, I guess, that it's really important to sort of save all these different rare breeds and not just have one breed of super sheep available. So our science is like flocking to North Ronald's to study the sheep and the sheep and save us from the agricultural to study the sheep and just like save us from being inundated with methane from
我确信，观察这里的这些绵羊会很有益处，它们一直在靠海藻生存。它们可能拥有这些独特的酶和肠道细菌，这对科学来说会非常有用。所以我想这很好地说明了，保护所有这些不同的珍稀品种并不仅仅拥有一种超级绵羊可供选择，是多么的重要。所以我们的科学家们正蜂拥至北罗纳德赛岛来研究绵羊，以及拯救我们免受农业……来研究绵羊，以此拯救我们免受来自绵羊屁的甲烷的淹没。
from sheepfarts. I think that some scientists have begun to look at this but but again like that's kind of been you know put on pause because of the pandemic. But yeah I think I think that would be a really fascinating thing to look at. And what is the climate contribution of the North Ronald Z sheep population? Maybe it's nothing. Maybe it isn't. Maybe they still have, maybe they still admit a lot of methane, but I think it's worth looking at. And so when Sean first got there, it was really more about just sort of the cultural heritage of preserving these sheep. But now there's sort of like this scientific reason too that like maybe these sheep have
我想有些科学家已经开始着手研究这个了，但同样地，这由于大流行而处于暂停状态。但是，是的，我想这会是一个非常迷人的研究课题。那么北罗纳德赛岛绵羊种群对气候的贡献是什么？也许什么都没有。也许不是。也许它们仍然……也许它们仍然排放大量的甲烷，但我认为这值得研究。所以当肖恩刚到那里时，它实际上更多是为了保护这些绵羊的文化遗产。但现在也有了这样一种科学上的原因，也许这些绵羊体内包含着重要的信息，对科学真正有益。
important information inside of them that could be beneficial for science really. Yeah, that's amazing. That makes it even more of a folk tale. It just goes to show how, you know, just like Sean said, like the importance of, you know, maintaining rare breeds and variety and culture because you never know what's gonna save us, you know? Yeah.
是的，这太棒了。这让它更像是一个民间故事了。这正好说明了，正如肖恩所说，保护珍稀品种、多样性和文化的重要性，因为你永远不知道是什么会拯救我们，你知道吗？是的。
It's really stunning. Well, that's such a good story. Oh, I love it. I love it. I'm gonna think about this a lot. Ha, ha, ha, ha. About being the wall builder on the island of North Ronsley. I now have a new dream job. That's like, that's right up there.
这真的太震撼了。好吧，这真是一个好故事。哦，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我会为此思考很久。哈哈哈哈。关于成为北罗纳德赛岛上的筑墙人。我现在有了新的梦想工作。这就像，这绝对名列前茅。
Yeah, well, I think Sean is serving a three-year term. So when it's over, maybe, you know. Oh, that's right. I'm gonna get my application ready. Yeah, or, you know, again, I know I've done, I've suggested you going to Scotland for to see the peat bogs like on on your way up from the peat bogs you could make it stop in and be a volunteer building the wall. I'm so on board with this. Like you think I might be joking just for the sake of doing it on the radio. Like I am so on board for this. All right, well, I'll let Sean know to expect your service.
是的，好吧，我想肖恩的任期是三年。所以当它结束时，也许，你知道。哦，对哦。我要去准备我的申请了。是的，或者，你知道，再次提醒，我知道我建议过你去苏格兰看泥炭沼泽……在你从泥炭沼泽回来的路上，你可以顺便去当个志愿者修墙。我太支持这个了。就像你可能认为我只是为了在广播里开玩笑才这么说。我是真心实意地支持这个。好吧，我会让肖恩知道期待你的服务的。
So there. Thank you so much, Emma. Thank you. So every publisher book, the 99% Invisible City, Kurt Colston and I went on Reddit to answer some questions from fans, and one of them asked us if we'd be interested in covering left-handedness. So Kurt wrote an article about the challenges of being a lefty in a world mainly designed for writings, but it also reminded him of another story that he's been wanting to tell. And it's about an object design, not just for left-handed or right-handed people, but for anyone anywhere.
就是这样。非常感谢，埃姆。谢谢。所以关于每一本出版的书，《99% 隐形城市》，库尔特·科尔斯顿和我去了 Reddit 回答粉丝的一些问题，其中一个问题问我们是否有兴趣报道左撇子。所以库尔特写了一篇文章，关于在一个主要为右撇子设计的世界里作为左撇子的挑战，但这页让他想起了另一个他一直想讲的故事。这是一个关于物体设计的故事，不是为左撇子或右撇子设计的，而是为世界上任何地方的任何人设计的。
And I do mean anywhere. Yes, anywhere. And this idea has been sitting on my shelf for a while. And it starts with this anecdote that I've heard since I was a kid. It's kind of like an urban legend or a joke. And it starts with this anecdote that I've heard since I was a kid. It's kind of like an urban legend or a joke. And it goes like this during the space race NASA supposedly spent millions of dollars developing a space bit while the Soviets just used a pencil. Right. Right. I've heard it too. I mean, it's pretty funny, but it totally sounds
我是说任何地方。是的，任何地方。这个想法在我的书架上放了一段时间了。它始于一个我从小听到大的轶事。它有点像都市传说或者笑话。它始于一个我从小听到大的轶事。它有点像都市传说或者笑话。它是这样的：在太空竞赛期间，美国宇航局据说花了几百万美元开发太空笔，而苏联人只是用铅笔。对。对。我也听过。我的意思是，这挺搞笑的，但听起来完全
focused. And it really is. The reality is that for a long time, both the US and Soviet space programs struggled to figure out ways to write in space. And they tried out things like regular pencils and mechanical pencils, but fragments of graphite floating around to be really dangerous. Even grease pencils could flake and break apart. And yeah, it's a really big mess. That was part of the story that's the part that never rang true to me. Because if you've ever sharpened a pencil, little things float around and like they're on the ground,
是编造的。确实如此。现实情况是，很长一段时间里，美国和苏联的太空计划都在努力寻找在太空中书写的方法。他们尝试过普通铅笔和自动铅笔等东西，但漂浮在空中的石墨碎屑非常危险。甚至油画铅笔也会剥落和碎裂。是的，这是一个超级大的麻烦。那是故事的一部分……从来没有让我觉得真实的一部分。因为如果你削过铅笔，小东西会四处飘浮，就像在地上一样，到处都是。
they're all over it. And you can imagine that just like working their way into any type of electronics or something. Like there's a reason why you wouldn't have a pencil in space. Absolutely. They have to keep track of everything up there. You can't have little particulates that could like clog the air filters or like mess with the electronics. I mean, this is like life threatening. Right, right. And so that's where this Fisher Space Pin actually does come in. Okay, so this sort of apocryphal nature of the two different styles and that's, you know,
你可以想象它们会钻进任何类型的电子设备或其他东西里。这就是为什么你不会在太空中使用铅笔的原因。绝对是的。他们必须追踪那里的每一样东西。你不能有任何可能堵塞空气过滤器或干扰电子设备的小颗粒。我的意思是，这简直是危及生命。没错，没错。这就是费舍尔太空笔真正派上用场的地方。好吧，所以这两种不同风格的这种杜撰性质，以及那是，你知道的，
like an inch of the waistfulness, you know, maybe a little bit heightened and a little bogus, but there was really a space pen that got made. Yeah, so like any good urban legend, there are bits of truth to this. Like it really did cost millions of dollars to develop, but it wasn't made by NASA. It was made for NASA and every other space agency that wanted one. And the guy who made it was named Pulfisher and he just took it upon himself to figure out how to make a pen for space that would work in any conditions like extreme temperatures, zero gravity, and he did all this R&D and he solved it.
有点像浪费，你知道，可能有点夸大其词，也有点虚假，但确实有一支被制造出来的太空笔。是的，就像任何好的都市传说一样，其中包含着真实的成分。它的确花了几百万美元来开发，但它不是由美国宇航局制造的。它是为美国宇航局以及所有其他想要它的太空机构制造的。制造它的人名叫保罗·费舍尔，他自己承担起弄清楚如何制造一支能在任何条件下（如极端温度、零重力）工作的太空笔的责任，他做了所有的研发，并解决了它。
Huh. And then did he just license it to all these space agencies like for millions of dollars? You know, I would have thought so and I might have done that if I were him. But no, he just he put it all this research and they just sold them basically at cost or you know, retail prices to any space agency that's interesting. And it turned out these were really important for these spaces agencies because keeping manual records in space of readouts from computers and everything else is really important. And it just kind of blows my mind that all these literal rocket scientists with their attention to detail and safety and everything else and be able to correct this thing. But this private businessman just said, I'm going to do it.
哼。然后他只是把专利授权给所有这些太空机构，换取数百万美元吗？你知道的，我以前也会这么想，如果我是他，我可能也会这么做。但没有，他投入了所有这些研究，然后基本上是以成本价或零售价将它们卖给任何太空机构，这很有趣。事实证明，这些对这些太空机构来说真的非常重要，因为在太空中对来自计算机和其他一切的读数进行人工记录是非常重要的。这让我感到震惊的是，所有这些名副其实的火箭科学家，他们对细节、安全和其他一切都一丝不苟，却无法解决这个小东西。但这个私营商人却说，我要做到这一点。
I'm going to solve this and I'm going to make a pen that writes in space. And so how did you do it? How did these magical pens actually work? The key basically is nitrogen pressurized, hermetically sealed ink cartridges. So if you think about it, like most pens use gravity to drain ink down onto a page, but these pins actively push the ink out. And while they're made for use in space, they proved pretty popular on Earth too, and they proved popular with right-handed people, but especially left-handed people too.
我要解决它，我要制造一支能在太空中书写的笔。那么他是怎么做到的呢？这些神奇的笔实际上是如何工作的？关键基本上是氮气加压、密封的墨盒。如果你想想看，大多数笔都是利用重力让墨水流向纸张的，但这些笔是主动将墨水推出来的。虽然它们是为太空使用而制造的，但在地球上也证明非常受欢迎，它们在右撇子中很受欢迎，但在左撇子中尤其受欢迎。
Okay, so tell me how a sort of anti-gravity pen can help a left-handed person in particular, like walk me through the mechanics of that. Right, so let's just imagine a ballpoint pen for comparison. Now, as a right-handed person, you hold it in your hand and you kind of drag it across the page, and that works fine, and gravity drains the ink out. But if you put it in your left hand and you're writing from left to right, you're basically working against the mechanism sort of jamming the pen into the page and the ink just doesn't flow properly. So yeah, because with the right hand, you're dragging it across the page and so you're pulling that ball with the ink on it, but with the left hand, you're pushing it into the page.
好吧，那么告诉我，一种反重力笔是如何专门帮助左撇子的，比如带我了解一下其中的力学原理。好的，我们来想象一支圆珠笔作为对比。作为一个右撇子，你把它握在手里，然后把它拖过纸面，这运作得很好，重力让墨水流出。但如果你把它放在左手里，并且从左到右书写，你基本上是在与机制对抗，有点像把笔强行戳进纸里，墨水就是无法正常流动。所以，是的，因为用右手时，你是把它拖过纸面的，所以你是在拉动带着墨水的那个小球，但用左手时，你是把它推向纸面的。
And therefore, the ink isn't flowing properly and getting it out there. That makes some sense. So with the space pen, it really doesn't matter how you hold it because it has the nitrogen pressurized ink. And so it just writes no matter what. Exactly. It has no directionality at all. You could be a righty.
因此，墨水无法正常流动并输送出来。这倒说得通。所以有了太空笔，你如何握笔真的不重要，因为它有氮气加压的墨水。所以无论如何它都能书写。没错。它根本没有方向性。你可以是个右撇子。
You could be a lefty. You could be sitting back in your chair and holding a pad up in the air and writing upside down if you want to. So it was made for people who are literally heading out to explore the universe, but it turns out to be a pretty neat universal design on Earth too.
你可以是个左撇子。你可以靠在椅子上，把一个本子举在空中，如果你愿意的话，还可以倒过来写。所以它是为那些字面意义上正要出发去探索宇宙的人制造的，但事实证明，它在地球上也是一种非常巧妙的通用设计。
Huh. It's almost like we should revise that apocryphal story and say every space agency in the world wanted a space pen and no agency actually did it, government agency did it, but a scrappy entrepreneur figured it out and sold it to them. That apocryphal story is used as an example of the wastefulness of a government-based bureaucracy, but it turns out that the true story is extremely American. Yeah, to this day, Fisher sells all these different space pins and encartages, and I even have one myself because it's nice to have, right? It's nice to have a pin where you don't have to worry
哼。这几乎就像我们应该修改那个杜撰的故事，并说世界上每一个太空机构都想要一支太空笔，而且没有任何机构真正做到过，政府机构没有做到，但一个精干的企业家搞明白了并把它卖给了他们。那个杜撰的故事被用作政府官僚机构浪费的一个例子，但事实证明，真实的故事极其美国化。是的，直到今天，费舍尔仍在销售所有这些不同的太空笔和笔芯，我自己甚至也有一支，因为拥有它很不错，对吧？拥有一支你不必担心
about it like drying out on your mid-sentence. You can just kind of throw it in your backpack and it goes anywhere with you. So I think it's great. Yeah, it's a very American entrepreneurial story. And I think personally that this is as good as the original story. I mean, the lesson of the original story, you know, keep it simple, government bureaucracy. That's a lesson we can learn in a lot of places. But this is just a lesson of tenacity and figuring out what turned out to be a relatively simple engineering solution, and then applying
它会在你写到一半时干掉的笔，感觉很好。你可以把它直接扔进背包里，它能和你去任何地方。所以我认为这很棒。是的，这是一个非常美国式的创业故事。而且我个人认为这和最初的故事一样精彩。我的意思是，最初故事的教训，你知道，保持简单，政府官僚主义。这是我们在很多地方都能学到的教训。但这只是一个关于坚韧的教训，弄清楚了一个最终证明是相对简单的工程解决方案，然后将其应用
it and selling it to the world. I mean, this is like more of a true story of design, of iteration, and perfection, and then being rewarded for it. Exactly. Exactly. So if you're interested in Kurt's longer article about the left-handed design, it's titled Left Behind appropriately, and you can find it embedded in this episode's web companion at 9ipi.org. If you celebrate Christmas in the traditional Western ways, probably within the past couple
并卖给全世界。我的意思是，这更像是一个真实的设计、迭代和完美的故事，并为此得到了回报。绝对的。绝对的。所以如果你对库尔特关于左撇子设计的更长篇文章感兴趣，它的标题恰如其分地叫作《落后》（Left Behind），你可以在 9ipi.org 本集的网页伴侣中找到它。如果你以传统的西方方式庆祝圣诞节，可能在过去几周里，
weeks, you had to contend with what to do with your old Christmas tree. Back when I lived in San Francisco, I remember that people would collect other people's trees from the curb before that green waste truck could pick them up and drag them all to Ocean Beach to make the biggest bonfire I've ever seen. The flames were like 50 feet tall, it actually scared me, but if you live in Nome, Alaska, your old Christmas tree serves a noble purpose. It will become part of the seasonal Nome National Forest. Each year, old Christmas trees are arranged on the barren sea ice in front of Nome, into
你不得不处理如何安置旧圣诞树的问题。当我还住在旧金山时，我记得人们会在绿化废弃物卡车来收走之前，从马路边收集别人的树，然后把它们全部拖到大洋海滩（Ocean Beach），燃起我见过最大的一场篝火。火焰有 50 英尺高，其实把我吓坏了。但如果你住在阿拉斯加州的诺姆（Nome），你的旧圣诞树就有了一个崇高的用途。它将成为季节性的诺姆国家森林的一部分。每年，旧圣诞树都会被排列在诺姆前面荒凉的海冰上，
a temporary display, which they accent with wooden stand-ups of cartoon characters and a sign that reads appropriately, gnome national forest. You can see pictures online. It is delightful and silly. And then, when the ice begins to melt, the caretakers collect the wooden cutouts and the sign. And eventually, the ice breaks up and carries the old Christmas trees out to sea.
排成一个临时的展览，他们用卡通人物的木制立牌和一块恰如其分地写着“诺姆国家森林”的牌子来点缀。你可以在网上看到照片。它既可爱又傻气。然后，当冰开始融化时，管理员会收走木制剪纸和牌子。最终，冰层融化断裂，将旧圣诞树带入大海。
We have more minis, after this. For this mini story, we're going to do something a little bit different. Every once in a while, with the help of the Autodesk Foundation, we like to cover impact design, which is designed that's focused on making the world a better place. And to that end, I'm talking with Zoe Besvanko, who is the impact and design lead at the Autodesk Foundation about some innovative design approaches to environmental sustainability, to what's I'm talking with Zoe Besvanko, who is the impact and design lead at the Autodesk Foundation about some innovative design approaches to environmental sustainability to what's known as circularity.
稍后我们还有更多迷你故事。对于这个迷你故事，我们要搞点不一样的东西。每隔一段时间，在欧特克基金会（Autodesk Foundation）的帮助下，我们喜欢报道影响力设计，也就是专注于让世界变得更美好的设计。为此，我正在与欧特克基金会的影响力与设计主管佐伊·贝斯万科（Zoe Besvanko）交谈，探讨一些关于环境可持续性的创新设计方法，也就是所谓的……我正在与欧特克基金会的影响力与设计主管佐伊·贝斯万科交谈，探讨一些关于环境可持续性的创新设计方法，也就是所谓的循环性（circularity）。
Hey Zoe. Hi. So, you've come on to talk to me a little bit about circularity and different companies that are thinking of circularity in new ways. So, first of all, let's just start with, what is the definition of circularity? The simple definition of circularity is to use a product at its highest value for as long as possible. And that can mean the product itself,
嗨，佐伊。嗨。所以，你来跟我聊聊关于循环性，以及以崭新方式思考循环性的不同公司。首先，让我们从一个问题开始：什么是循环性的定义？循环性的简单定义是以最高价值使用一个产品尽可能长的时间。这可以指产品本身，
its material or the component it's made of. And for this, you need to build circular system or closed loop system that basically minimized the use of resources input and the creation of waste. And this is opposed to a linear system in which you get a bunch of materials, you manufacture it into something, and then eventually you just throw that thing away. So straight line to the garbage dump.
它的材料或它所由之制造的组件。为此，你需要建立一个循环系统或闭环系统，基本上要最大限度地减少资源投入的使用以及废物的产生。这与线性系统形成了鲜明对比，在线性系统中，你获得一堆材料，将其制造某种东西，然后最终你只需把那东西扔掉。也就是通往垃圾场的直线。
Yeah. So Closeloup systems like reusing, sharing, repairing, refurbishing, remanufacturing, recycling are regenerative by design. I think most people, when they probably hear the word circularity, they probably think of the word recycling. What is the difference between the two? So, I mean, recycling is one piece of the puzzle for circularity and it's a great promise, but it's not working alone, you know? Otherwise, we wouldn't be sending so much into landfill. Actually, today we recycle, you know,
是的。所以闭环系统，如重复使用、共享、修理、翻新、再制造、回收，在设计上就是再生性的。我想大多数人听到“循环性”这个词时，可能首先会想到“回收”这个词。这两者有什么区别呢？所以，我的意思是，回收是循环性拼图中的一块，它是一个美好的承诺，但它不能单打独斗，你知道吗？否则，我们就不会把那么多东西送往垃圾填埋场了。事实上，今天我们回收了，你知道的，
9% of our plastic, I think overall, no waste, it's about 30%. 9% of plastic, wow. The difference is, I think, security is that it goes way beyond recycling. It's thinking about other models, like we're using, I think manufacturing, like we're forbishing.
9% 的塑料，我想总的来说，无废弃物，大概是 30%。9% 的塑料，哇。区别在于，我认为循环性在于它远超回收。它在思考其他模式，比如重复使用、再制造、翻新。
It's also based into not only the material that the products are made of, meaning that we're recycling cans into cans, paper into paper and so forth. But it's really thinking about the product, their design and the way they're manufactured. So, so thinking about the business model in which this product are being built, and then the infrastructure that support this product lifecycle, meaning both the infrastructure that are hardware, like the waste management facility, but also the infrastructure that are software and the data that inside the information that flows across the product lifecycle.
它不仅基于产品所使用的材料，这意味着我们将易拉罐回收成易拉罐，纸张回收成纸张等等。而且它真正考虑的是产品、它们的设计以及它们的制造方式。因此，还要考虑构建这些产品的商业模式，以及支持该产品生命周期的基础设施，既指硬件基础设施，如废物管理设施，也指软件基础设施以及在产品生命周期中流动的信息数据。
So you've come to us today with a few examples of companies using circularity in innovative ways to try to explain the concept. So what is the first one you have on on back? The first one is the company called 57 Street Design and I love them because they're really about rescinding the design and the manufacturing of the products. So 57 Street Design and they make furniture. They build something called design circulation, which is a survey that take back, restore and recirculate the furniture. And they really had to rethink the design itself of this furniture so that they can create a system
所以你今天给我们带来了一些公司以创新方式利用循环性来试图解释这个概念的例子。那么你在背包里的第一个例子是什么？第一个是一家名为 57 Street Design 的公司，我非常喜欢他们，因为他们真正致力于重新思考产品的设计和制造。所以 57 Street Design，他们制造家具。他们建造了一种叫做设计循环（design circulation）的东西，这是一个回收、修复和循环家具的调查。他们确实不得不重新思考这件家具本身的设计，以便他们能够创建一个系统
where they never discard anything in the furniture, but rather they recirculate them from home to home in perpetually basically. How did they make sure that a table that's potentially you know, potentially trashed in one home is being used as another piece of furniture and another home eventually? They have different design principle. The first one is that they're using solid hardwoods and handwrapped finishes to ease the repairability and the durability of this product. That makes sense. Just make things a priority and then you don't throw them away.
在这个系统中，他们从不丢弃家具中的任何东西，而是基本上让它们在各个家庭之间永久地循环。他们如何确保可能在一个家庭中被丢弃的桌子，最终能在另一个家庭中作为另一件家具被使用呢？他们有不同的设计原则。首先，他们使用实木硬木和手工包裹的饰面，以简化该产品的可修复性和耐用性。这说得通。只要把事情放在首位，那么你就不必把它们扔掉了。
The second is around standardization. So they are working into having parts of this furniture that can be transferred from one type of furniture to the other. For instance, if your table legs are broken, you can replace them with chair legs or replace part of the stable into a bed, for instance. They're also thinking about the ease of disassembly so that they can repair the bespoke's part of their furniture. And that's interesting because typically when you think ease of assembly and disassembly of furniture, you think of IKEA and typically IKEA are kind of almost single-use furniture unfortunately in our society today.
第二个是关于标准化。因此，他们正致力于让这些家具的零件可以从一种家具转移到另一种家具。例如，如果你的桌腿坏了，你可以用椅子腿替换它们，或者把这张桌子的部分部件换成一张床，等等。他们还在考虑易于拆卸性，以便他们可以修理家具的定制部件。这很有趣，因为通常当你想到家具的易组装和易拆卸时，你会想到宜家，而不幸的是，在当今社会，宜家通常几乎是一次性家具。
The opposite of circular, it just goes in one direction. Exactly, but here they are taking the same principle associated to ready-to-assemble design, but with the mindset that you can easily disassemble them and therefore repair bespoke parts of this design and this furniture. So it sounds like the real, the innovation in total with them is like to use the design of the product to aid circularity, everything is made so it can be disassembled, reused, refurbished. And this is a fundamental part of the design, it's not done after the fact. reused, refurbished. And this is a fundamental part of the design. It's not done after the fact. Exactly. And I keep on saying, you will not recycle something if it hasn't been designed to be recycled. It's already hard to recycle something when it has been designed to be recycled. So,
与循环相反，它只朝一个方向发展。没错，但在这里，他们采用了与即装即配设计相关的相同原则，但带有这样的心态：你可以轻松地拆卸它们，从而修理这个设计和这件家具的定制部件。所以听起来，他们整体上的真正创新是利用产品的设计来辅助循环性，一切都是为了能够被拆卸、重复使用、翻新而制造的。这是设计的基本组成部分，而不是事后才去做的。重复使用、翻新。这是设计的基本组成部分。这不是事后才去做的。没错。我一直说，如果一件东西没有被设计成可回收的，你就不会去回收它。当一件东西被设计成可回收时，回收它就已经很难了。所以，
if it's not. So, this is really, I think, your company that exemplified ideas, like thinking, circular, at the design space Circularity starts with design. So what's another aspect of circularity, where there are some innovative approaches out there that you've seen? So I've talked to you about the importance of rethinking our infrastructure. It was from a hardware and software,
如果不是这样的话。所以这真的，我认为，是一家体现了这些理念的公司，比如在设计空间里思考循环性。循环性始于设计。那么循环性的另一个方面是什么，你见过哪些创新的方法？所以我和你谈过重新思考我们基础设施的重要性。这是从硬件和软件的角度出发的。
almost perspective. And I think there's a company that exemplifies that quite well called AMP Robotics, AMP Robotics. And they make AI-based robots to improve waste certification at waste management facility. So at a high level, it's basically robot that tic-up trash on the the certification line in this facility. Right. So there's a conveyor belt and the robot senses what's what pulls out the recycling stuff. Or like maybe pushes it with a puff of air and separates it from the trash.
几乎是这样的角度。我认为有一家名为 AMP Robotics（AMP 机器人）的公司很好地体现了这一点，即 AMP Robotics。他们制造基于人工智能的机器人来改善废物管理设施中的废物分类。所以从宏观层面来看，基本上就是机器人在这些设施的分类线上捡起垃圾。没错。所以有一条传送带，机器人能感知什么是什么，并把回收的东西挑出来。或者像用一股气流把它推开，并把它从垃圾中分离出来。
Exactly. And so these robots are trained in recognizing material type and different types of trash. And to train these robots and probiotic needs a lot of data, aka, basically pictures of trash to help them recognize. Emprobaric is today so successful at what they're doing that major consumer brands are proactively sending them pictures or design of their new products before they even hit the market so that the robots can learn these new recycling trash that are coming their way.
完全正确。因此，这些机器人经过训练，能够识别材料类型和不同种类的垃圾。为了训练这些机器人，Amphibotic 需要大量的数据，也就是垃圾的照片来帮助它们识别。Amphibotic 目前在他们所做的事情上非常成功，以至于各大消费品牌都在主动向他们发送新产品的照片或设计，甚至在这些产品上市之前就发送，以便机器人能够学习即将来临的新回收垃圾。
Like, for example, they are currently working with caring Dr. Paper that introduced new recyclable cake up pods for Kofi. This cake up pod is like, it's like the single serving coffee thing that goes into a press. You probably know or maybe not, but cake up pods are non-recyclable. And so, you know, when now they're going into a recycling management facility, they are not sorted out and they go straight to landfill. Now that you have one brand doing recyclable cake up pod, how do you sort specifically this cake up pod? And so the example here that they gave me was that they are working directly with the company on ensuring that the robot can recognize this specific cake up pod and sort them so that they end up in proper recycling
例如，他们目前正与 Keurig Dr Pepper 合作，后者为咖啡推出了新型可回收的 K-Cup 胶囊。这个 K-Cup 胶囊就像是放入咖啡机的单份装咖啡。你可能知道，也可能不知道，K-Cup 胶囊是不可回收的。因此，当它们现在进入回收管理设施时，不会被分类，而是直接进入垃圾填埋场。现在，当你有一个品牌生产可回收的 K-Cup 胶囊时，你如何专门对这种 K-Cup 胶囊进行分类？他们给我的例子是，他们正与该公司直接合作，确保机器人能够识别这种特定的 K-Cup 胶囊并对其进行分类，以便它们最终进入正确的回收
streams. So in essence, what's happening is to ensure circularity of materials, the companies that make things and make bottles and holders and little single serving packs of ground coffee are feeding that information to amphrobatics so that when they come into the the waste stream, they recognize them and know how to recycle them. Exactly. Yeah. And I think today one really one of the issue that we run into is that designers don't have the right information of what can be recycled or not.
渠道。因此，实质上，为了确保材料的循环性，制造物品、瓶子、支架和碎咖啡单份小包装的公司正在将这些信息提供给 Amphibotics，以便当它们进入废物处理流时，机器人能够识别它们并知道如何回收它们。没错。是的。而且我认为今天我们遇到的真正问题之一是，设计师没有关于什么可以回收或不可以回收的正确信息。
And then waste management facility have limited information about what is coming their way and therefore they can't adapt their infrastructure to actually handle what needs to be recycled. And so what's really interesting with ImproBotic is that they are connecting the dots and basically closing the loop, as we like to say, in circularity with both the data and the insights from flowing from this company to the
而且废物管理设施关于将要处理的废弃物的信息有限，因此他们无法调整其基础设施来实际处理需要回收的东西。因此，AmproBotic 非常有趣的地方在于，他们正在连接各个点，基本上正如我们喜欢说的那样，通过来自这些公司的流动数据和洞察，闭合循环
waste management facility and the hardware that is actually making the certification process more efficient. So what's another aspect of circularity that other companies are using to make the world less wasteful? Yeah and the last example is a little bit maybe starts starts with similar story that we've heard about circularity, which is really around, how are we handling the amount of waste that we are sitting on right now and kind of solving also the plastic problem. And so it's a company called the plastic road and the recycling plastic into prefabricated roads.
废物管理设施以及使认证过程更高效的硬件。那么，其他公司正在利用循环性的另一个方面是什么，来减少世界的浪费？是的，最后一个例子可能有点类似于我们听过的关于循环利用的相似故事，它实际上围绕着：我们如何处理我们目前面临的大量废物，并顺便解决塑料问题。所以有一家公司叫 PlasticRoad，他们把回收的塑料制成预制道路。
They are actually modular pieces of road that are containing a drainage system and they work like a Lego box. So you can just put them in and assemble it into the road and actually it can also be pulled out pretty easily. It's using recycled content. It also can be recycled multiple time. Yeah. And so these are modular roads, so it's kind of like a pre-made piece of plastic that you can
它们实际上是包含排水系统的模块化道路部件，工作原理就像乐高积木一样。因此，你可以直接将它们放入并组装成道路，而且实际上也很容易拆卸。它使用的是回收材料。它也可以多次循环利用。是的。所以这些是模块化道路，它有点像预制的塑料块，你可以
drive over with your bike, or are they made for cars as well? Yeah, they started with some bike lane, and they have made some strength tests that shows that cars can drive them on as well. And so therefore, you can lay down a road that has better drainage because it's sort of manufactured in this way and it can be laid down really quickly because the pieces are pre-fab and joined together and then it's a road.
骑着自行车从上面驶过，还是它们也是为汽车制造的？是的，他们从一些自行车道开始，并进行了一些强度测试，表明汽车也可以在上面行驶。因此，你可以铺设一条具有更好排水性能的道路，因为它是以这种方式制造的，而且可以非常迅速地铺设，因为这些部件是预制的并连接在一起，然后就成了一条路。
Exactly. I mean, it says like it's faster to build because it is pre-fab and it's just a Lego box. It's much lighter, less carbon emission because it comes from recycled sources and doesn't require any excavation, no heavy foundation, no concrete or assaults later. When you think about the concept of circularity, what is this project or tapping into for you? What is it achieving that gives you some kind of hope or you think is on the right track?
没错。我的意思是，这听起来建造速度更快，因为它是预制的，就像乐高积木一样。它轻得多，碳排放更少，因为它来自回收来源，不需要任何开挖，不需要沉重的地基，也不需要后来的混凝土或沥青。当你思考循环性的概念时，这个项目对你来说是在利用什么？它实现了什么，带给你某种希望或让你觉得走在正确的轨道上？
It's kind of this concept that we dig sinker and circularity love to talk and it's the idea of CDS material banks. And the idea that when you're going to build something new, you can look into what is already there into your own CD and maybe what is soon to be demolished that you could recycle or reuse. And you know, this idea of cities as material bank is also the idea of like all building and infrastructure can become material resources for a new building, new infrastructure and other industry within that CD.
这有点像我们“城市沉思者”和循环经济倡导者喜欢谈论的概念，也就是“城市作为材料库”的想法。这个想法是，当你打算建造新东西时，你可以查看你自己的城市中已经存在的东西，也许还有很快将被拆除的东西，你可以将其回收或重复利用。你知道，城市作为材料库的想法也意味着所有建筑物和基础设施都可以成为新建筑、新基础设施以及该城市内其他行业的材料资源。
Yeah. I think that's really like the most about these examples is that the heart of this seems to be about sharing information. So if you know that this much plastic is generated by your city over time or that building is going to come down and all the steel is going to be made available, then you know what you can build. And as long as you have all that information, it's passed through to the right people. You can close the loop on your circularity by really just having this material bank as you call it to reach
是的。我认为这些例子最棒的地方在于，其核心似乎是关于信息共享。因此，如果你知道你的城市随着时间推移产生了这么多塑料，或者那栋建筑将被拆除并且所有的钢材都将可用，那么你就知道你可以建造什么。只要你拥有所有这些信息，并将其传递给合适的人，你就可以通过拥有你所说的材料库来闭合循环，从而进行取用
into and then build things with without creating more waste. It's kind of stunning. And it's also just like, it's my favorite part of design is the part of it that's common sense. And so the hurdle that it seems like, you know, is that the method for obtaining new materials is so streamlined and simple. And the method for getting used materials is more complicated. And it seems like the big hurdle then is to just make the both the information and access to recycled materials as easy to get as it is
并建造东西，而不会产生更多的废物。这有点惊人。而且这也是设计中最让我喜欢的部分，也就是它充满常识的那一部分。因此，似乎存在的障碍是，获取新材料的方法是如此简化和简单。而获取旧材料的方法则更加复杂。因此，巨大的障碍似乎就是让信息和对回收材料的获取变得和
to order something new out of a catalog. Exactly. I mean, I think your your comment on information and data is really spot on. It's like, circularity is really going to be on look when we have information that flows throughout the entire lifecycle and value chain of products, material and components. And we really need to have data at the center that start connecting stakeholders throughout this life cycle. So even the example of connecting designer with waste management facility, but there is also materials to players with manufacturers and so forth. You can look at it in different
从目录中订购新东西一样容易。没错。我的意思是，你对信息和数据的评论非常中肯。这就好比，当我们拥有贯穿产品、材料和组件整个生命周期和价值链的信息流动时，循环性才会真正开启。我们确实需要将数据置于核心地位，开始连接整个生命周期的利益相关者。因此，甚至将设计师与废物管理设施连接起来的例子也是如此，此外还有材料供应商与制造商等等。你可以从不同的角度来看待它
and go throughout that cycle. I think there is another thing is also a concept that, you know, typically with sort of that single mindset of recycling and once again the idea that we are recovering material to make always the same product. There is this concept that material then downgrade and therefore, loads value. And really to unlock circularity, we need to sort of cross-pollinate these value chains so that maybe the waste from one industry becomes really valuable in another industry. And we stop kind of this vicious circle of this downgrade
并在整个周期中推进。我认为还有一件事也是一个概念，你知道，通常带着那种单一的回收思维模式，再次认为我们正在回收材料以制造永远相同的产品的想法。这里有一个概念，即材料随后会降级，从而失去价值。为了真正释放循环性，我们需要将这些价值链进行交叉融合，以便一个行业的废物在另一个行业中变得非常有价值。我们停止这种降级的恶性循环
of value and material, sort of, stretch the value chain. Because if you were to endlessly recycle a plastic bottle, eventually the plastic becomes so degraded that it doesn't serve as a plastic bottle anymore. But if you took a somewhat degraded plastic bottle, you could make the perfect road with it. And therefore, it doesn't get degraded in the same way. And so, like, it's like the old adage of one man's trashes, another man's treasure. Exactly. But today, the information doesn't leave a single industry. And even within an industry, their offense doesn't even leave a single company. So how do you unlock that information so that the next person building their roads know
价值和材料，算是延伸了价值链。因为如果你无休止地回收一个塑料瓶，最终塑料会退化得如此严重，以至于它不再能作为塑料瓶使用。但是，如果你拿一个略微退化的塑料瓶，你可以用它来建造完美的道路。因此，它不会以同样的方式退化。所以，这就好比那句老话：“一个人的垃圾，另一个人的宝藏。”没错。但今天，信息并没有离开单一行业。甚至在一个行业内部，信息甚至没有离开单一公司。那么，你如何释放这些信息，以便下一个建造道路的人知道
that there is all this pile of plastic trash in this factory waiting for someone to use it? 99% of visible's impact design coverage is supported by Autodesk. Autodesk enables the design and creation of innovative solutions to the world's most pressing, social, and environmental challenges. Learn more about these efforts on Autodesk Redshift. That's Autodesk.com slash Redshift, a site that tells stories about the future of making things across architecture, engineering, infrastructure, construction and manufacturing. At the beginning of 2021 and what a 2021 it has been so far, 99% invisible is Katie Minkle, Kurt Colstad, Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sean Rihau, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Le, Sophia
这家工厂里堆积了所有这些塑料垃圾，正等待着有人来使用它？99% Invisible 的影响力设计报道得到了 Autodesk 的支持。Autodesk 支持设计和创造创新解决方案，以应对世界上最紧迫的社会和环境挑战。请在 Autodesk Redshift 上了解有关这些努力的更多信息。网址是 Autodesk.com/slash/Redshift，这是一个讲述建筑、工程、基础设施、施工和制造领域制造未来的故事的网站。在 2021 年初，2021 年过得真是丰富多彩，99% Invisible 的成员有：Katie Minkle、Kurt Colstad、Delaney Hall、Emmett Fitzgerald、Sean Rihau、Joe Rosenberg、Vivian Le、Sophia
Klatsker, Chris Marube, Abby McDonald, Christopher Johnson, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 9.1.7K, a WN San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Discover, listen, and support them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org.
Klatsker、Chris Marube、Abby McDonald、Christopher Johnson，以及我 Roman Mars。我们是 9.1.7K 的一个项目，这是旧金山的 KALW，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心 Radio Row 制作。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最棒、最具创新性节目的联盟。请在 radiotopia.fm 上发现、收听和支持他们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，以及@节目 @99PI org。
We're on Instagram and right at two. If you like these mini stories, we have one more for you next week, but we have years and years of them going back and they are always fan favorites and you can find them all at 99PI.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在 Instagram 上，地址是 two。如果你喜欢这些迷你故事，我们下周还为你准备了一个，但我们有积攒多年的故事，它们一直是粉丝的最爱，你可以在 99PI.org 上找到它们。Radiotopia，来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。